[Music]
310
[Music]
what happened
[Music]
why can't we all say
[Music]
i guess
[Music]
just
i will find my way back to you
little people in a little town
little mines just always get me down
your skin to them
[Music]
see us how to reach
[Music]
[Music]
just know i will find my way back to you
i will find my way back
[Music]
[Music]
i will find my way back to
what's going on
my name is tony constance this is my
amazing band
gonna play some tracks um of my recent
ep and my ep that also came out last
year
[Music]
we only ever had just enough
but i guess it left more room for love
if i drew blood
could told me to suck it up
i was raised by a woman and a warrior no
i'm not
[Music]
[Applause]
sure
[Music]
through heaven
[Music]
if
is
[Music]
is
[Music]
electric go
[Music]
knows that life could change
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
have you seen her
[Music]
oh
[Music]
anxiety
[Music]
wow
[Music]
wow
thank you guys
thank you so much british council
select a radio jam supernova having us
here
this is my band this is kelvin on the
base
[Applause]
got ricky lee on guitar
and we got rudy on drums
[Music]
we've got one last song for you and this
one's called monty python
[Music]
[Music]
last night
i was so high
i thought i had a crush on you
i looked deep into your eyes
and told you all the things
[Music]
[Music]
are you credit cards
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
last night
i was so high
i thought that we were hollywood
spotlight was on me so bright
[Music]
i wouldn't stop it if i could dirty
dancing next to you you saw the blood of
a rich
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
god's on the table you might create your
brain mine never changes and good in
ship keeps sailing in circles she lies
your way can't escape rest and play crap
woohoo
oh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you guys so much